der Abstand zwischen Superreichen und
Normalbevölkerung ist so groß wie nie
das sagt der Bericht der
Entwicklungsorganisation Oxfam in
Deutschland flossen demnach 81% des
Vermögenszuwachses der zwischen 20 und
2021 erwirtschaftet wurde an das
reichste Prozent der Bevölkerung und
gleichzeitig sind diese Zahl der
Sparkassenverband schätzt dass bald 60%
der deutschen Haushalte ihr monatliches
Einkommen komplett für die
Lebenserhaltung einsetzen müssen sprich
alles ist weg nichts bleibt übrig Arm
trotz Arbeit und das in einem der
reichsten Länder der Welt wie kann das
eigentlich sein Ramsauer haben sie eine
Antwort darauf viele Antworten habe ich
da drauf das hat aber in dem Thema
grundsteuererklärung nichts
drauf nur so viel
das hat natürlich mit Statistik zu tun
und die Absurdität dieser
oxfam-argumentation die sieht man schon
daran wenn sie für alle das Vermögen
verdoppeln oder wenn Sie für alle das
Einkommen verdoppeln
nimmt statistisch die Armut zu
also völlig verrückt ist ja ganz klar
das ist Effekt und so weiter und wer
oxfarm kennt das ist ja eine ganz
spezielle Organisation in
Anführungszeichen ich hatte mit denen
einiges zu tun ich nehme das ganze nicht
ernst
zwischen Arm und Reich viele Menschen
die jetzt kämpfen die sich fragen wie
zahle ich meine Lebensmittel wie zahle
ich meine Energiekosten während andere
auch firmenkonzerne profitieren selbst
in der Krise selbst in der Pandemie
selbst durch die Inflation es besorgt
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger das ist
vollkommen klar aber da würde ich eher
jemand aus der ampelregierung Fragen und
nicht einen Vertreter der Opposition
obwohl wir das natürlich aufgreifen
jetzt wenn ich einmal argumentiere
Aussicht der Ampel Parteien dann konnte
man sagen dass die Ampel wenigstens
versucht diese Dinge aufzugreifen also
mit ausgleichen bei den Energiepreisen
mit in die gaspreisbremse
strompreisbremse die ganzen
übergangshilfen die wir schon in der
Pandemie hatten und die jetzt auch
übrigens nicht nur für die Privatleute
greifen sollen sondern auch für Betriebe
Handwerksbetriebe dass die über die
Runden kommen also der Wille zur Hilfe
ist in der Ampel schon da und wir werden
als Opposition das natürlich sehr
kritisch begleiten das ist fast schon
ein Lob für ihre Partei die in der
Regierung hier sitzt Herrscher dennoch
bei 60 Prozent bleibt nichts mehr übrig
die können nicht sparen für einen Urlaub
für ein Häuschen für irgendwelche Ziele
wie sehr besorgt sie solche Zahlen
ja wir haben ganz so weg diskutieren wie
Herr Ramsauer würde ich es nicht und
sagen das ist nur Statistik er hat ja
trotzdem den Punkt gemacht mit dem Blick
darauf dass wir dahin schauen müssen wir
sind in einer Zeit von multiplen Krisen
es werden immer mehr Herausforderungen
erst der der Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine dann die Fragen die sich daraus
ableitende Inflation dann immer noch die
Schmerzen der corona-pandemie all das
führt zusammen zu einem schwierigen
Lagebild und deshalb müssen wir jetzt
hinschauen dass wir kurz und
mittelfristig entlasten dazu haben wir
entlastungspakete gemacht die Ampel
wurde gerade angesprochen wir müssen
aber auch gucken dass wir die Mitte in
unserem Land stärken und tatsächlich für
den Mittelstand in unserem Land
strukturelle auch Entlastung und
langfristige Fragen auch der
Steuerpolitik angehen damit wir dieses
Land weiter stabilisieren und ähm aus
dieser Krise im Idealfall sogar besser
hervorgehen als wir vorher reingegangen
sind sie gehören beispielsweise zur
Mitte glaube ich kann man so sagen ist
das für Sie alles nur Statistik sind das
nur Zahlen die sich noch gar nicht so
richtig spürbar machen doch natürlich
macht sich das spürbar also es macht
sich schon spürbar wenn Sie einkaufen
gehen und sie haben Produkte für die
Zahlen sie mittlerweile das Doppelte und
noch mehr und
ich würde jetzt sagen ich gehöre noch zu
den Leuten die uns relativ gut geht ja
aber ich habe in meinem Umfeld Leute die
jetzt wirklich zum Beispiel und das ist
tatsächlich so die Heizung ausgestellt
haben die einfach gesagt haben wir
können uns die Heizung im Moment nicht
leisten ja oder die plötzlich abends im
Dunkeln sitzen weil sie einfach sagen
unser Stromanbieter hat die Strompreise
so dermaßen erhöht wir können das nicht
bezahlen ja und das trifft vor allen
Dingen Rentner und wissen Sie ich war
über zehn Jahre auch Arbeitsvermittlerin
Unternehmensberaterin und ich frage mich
immer wer denkt sich den Mindestlohn aus
das ist so weit weg von der Realität und
da du kannst damit nicht existieren ja
und ähm ich die Kluft zwischen Arm und
Reich wird ja immer größer das ist ja
bekannt und wir haben den höchsten Stand
der Kinderarmut Zeit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg auch diese Zahlen sind nicht
weg zu diskutieren und ich frage mich
immer warum ist das so warum also auch
diese Hilfspakete die die Politik jetzt
eben anbietet die sind ja nötig weil die
Politik eben in die falsche Richtung
geht und das ist so ein bisschen als
wenn ich ausholen ihnen Ohrfeige
verpasse und gebe ihnen hinterher ein
Eisbeutel damit es nicht so weh tut und
das ist das was die Politik im Moment
macht sie macht eine Politik die
notwendig macht das Hilfspakete auf dem
Weg geschickt werden und das ist an der
Sache vorbei und das hilft auch den
Leuten nicht das ist ein Tropfen auf dem
heißen Sterne
von außen oder muss man sich da auch in
die Verantwortung nehmen die Ohrfeige
die man auch selbst verteilt hat also
ähm jetzt könnte ich es mir einfach
machen schlanken Fuß und sagen das muss
heran sauer beantworten mit 16 Jahre
Angela Merkel und der Frage was ist
strukturell richtig und was es
vielleicht auch strukturell falsch
gelaufen an diesen Stellen aber auch das
wäre zu kurz gesprungen weil die Sorgen
sind ja jetzt da sie haben es ja gerade
gesagt man sieht das ja wenn man
einkaufen geht man erlebt das ja im
Alltag man sieht das bei der
Stromrechnung wir haben das gerade hier
in Berlin dass der Staat
inflationsgewinner ist hier im Land
Berlin wird während die Netzentgelte 35%
Kostensteigerung die der Staat sich in
die Tasche steckt ich finde das darf
nicht passieren dass der Staat sich als
Krisengewinner sieht sondern da wo der
Staat in der Verantwortung ist wo man
immer gesagt hat wer rekommunalisieren
weil es für dich als Verbraucher am Ende
besser ist sollte jetzt auch für den
Verbraucher sich das Auszahlen und hier
zahlt sich gerade nicht aus wenn man z.B
auch bei den 7% Steigerung bleiben bei
der BSR und den Müllgebühren in der
Stadt Berlin also ich kann den Alltag
einmal durchlaufen wo der Staat
entlasten könnte damit tatsächlich dort
wo wir nicht dran kommen Geld vorhanden
ist um das
noch leisten zu können also man kann was
tun an Vorschlägen und Ideen mangels
nicht wir müssen politisch machen
deswegen will ich nicht wegdiskutieren
und dennoch gehört auch zur Wahrheit
dazu dass die Frage des Angriffskrieges
auf die Ukraine natürlich etwas ist was
für alle hier politisch nicht
vorhersehbar war und wo drauf man mit
den entsprechenden Maßnahmen und
Hilfspaketen ich glaube da sind wir
einer Meinung absolut reagieren muss
die Problematiken gibt es ja schon viel
länger also wenn ich mal überlege dass
wir schon seit Jahrzehnten ein ganz
massiven Wohnungsmangel in Deutschland
haben aber das auch schon seit
Jahrzehnten kaum noch soziale
Wohnungsbau betrieben wird während wir
aber Millionen Menschen die auf
Sozialwohnungen angewiesen sind ins Land
holen aber die Leute die die
ursprungsbevölkerung schon kein
bezahlbaren Wohnraum hat Familie mit
drei und vier Kinder auf 50
Quadratmetern Leben und das ist keine
Ausnahme
dann frage ich mich schon aber wo ist
doch ein einfaches Mittel woran liegt es
denn wir haben und zwar ein Zuzug an
Menschen aber wir haben keinen
sozialen Wohnungsbau
überhaupt keinen Wohnungsbau der
ausreichen würde die steigende
Bevölkerung aufzunehmen daran man muss
mehr Wohnungen die Wirtschaft muss mehr
Brummen auch im mittelständischen
Bereich nicht nur die Großkonzerne wir
haben aber eine Abwanderung von
Wirtschaftsunternehmen auch im
mittelständischen Bereich wir haben
Energiekosten die wahnsinnig hoch sind
die natürlich zum Teil zu der Misere
beitragen wenn ich sogar verantwortlich
sind und wenn ich mir aber die
Energiepolitik anschaue das Herumgeeiere
um die Kernkraft dann muss ich sagen wir
wollen hier Elektromobilität schaffen
wir wollen den Stromverbrauch steigern
aber wir haben eigentlich keine echte
Antwort wo der Strom denn herkommen soll
ich meine das geht nicht und das
letztendlich Baden dass die Bürger aus
und das badet der Mittelstand aus mehr
noch als die unteren Schichten weil die
hilft Rakete und die ganzen Markt für
die unteren Schichten sind nicht für den
Mittelstand der Mittelstand ist glaube
ich die Gruppe die am meisten darunter
leidet weil sie gewohnt ist alles
alleine aus eigener Verantwortung zu
wuppen und jetzt merkt das funktioniert
nicht mehr und da muss ich sagen
da braucht man auch keine Hilfspakete
die Leute wollen ja nicht abhängig sein
die wollen von ihrer Hände Arbeit leben
und das muss man ihn ermöglichen
Steuerpolitik da gebe ich ihnen ganz
recht die Abgaben sind wahnsinnig hoch
gerade für Menschen die arbeiten und die
hohe Kosten haben die die
Kindergartengebühren zahlen die auch
sonst alles bezahlen deshalb
Steuereinnahmen die Menschen eine
Million
andert statt finanzieren die müssten das
auch tun können und das muss der Staat
in ermöglicht nicht mit allem muss
sondern der scheidenbedingungen also
doch nicht nur Statistik doch nicht nur
Zahlen haben soll jetzt kriegen wir eine
Lebenswirklichkeit von vielen Menschen
mit der Mittelstand der sich im Stich
gelassen fühlt der der
sich allein gelassen fühlt sie hatten
gerade Lob für die Ampel sehen Sie das
jetzt immer noch so sie machen ein Lob
daraus aber man muss
man muss das sage ich jetzt mal noch
über 32 Jahren bundestagserfahrung und
Bundeskabinett und so
20 dezember 1990 es wird nächstes Jahr
am 20 April auf dem Tag genau ein
Drittel jahrhundert im Bundestag das
andere da können sie mich einladen dann
um 20 Uhr
weil wir gerade auch vor Weihnachten
noch 50 Jahre Wolfgang Schäuble Moment
Liebe Büro Nachbar aber zurück zu ihrer
zu Ihrer Frage ist Wirklichkeit genau
genau genau
Wirklichkeit er ist gehört einfach zur
Ferne ist dass man gute Ansätze in
Markierung auch mal benennt aus der
Opposition heraus und ich weiß ja wohl
lieber Kollege Czaja wie schwierig das
das für jede der ampelpartei ist das
alle drei im Grunde genommen das
Gegenteil von dem tun müssen wofür sie
eigentlich bei der letzten Wahl standen
aber lebenswirkungen
aber die Frage war Lebenswirklichkeit in
meiner Zeit als bundesverkehrsministerin
als bundesbahnminister sind wir all
diese Dinge natürlich jeden Tag auf den
Schreibtisch gekommen ich habe mir auch
zum Ziel gesetzt jährlich 400.000
Wohnungen neu zu bauen endet im sozial
geförderten Wohnungsbau Zweibrücken im
Freien Wohnungsbau Eigenheim bis große
mietwohnungs- und so weiter und dann
bist du täglich und wöchentlich
konfrontiert mit unzähligen Hindernissen
die dir kreuz und quer reingehauen
werden sozialer Wohnungsbau ist sehr
stark auch länderbezogen was die
Bundesländer machen müssen und dann
bekommt man von denen Antworten ja
genommen wird denn dahin das haben wir
noch nie anders gemacht wenn wir das
jetzt ändern würden das tun wir nicht
und da wirst du halb verrückt immerhin
im Zimmer von 190.000 damals 2009 auf
knapp 300.000 gekommen aber die Kollegin
geibels die beneide ich nicht die hat
sich auch 400.000 zum Beispiel
sind die Länder zuständig da ist die
Bürokratie zu schwierig das können wir
noch nicht da macht gehen
wir machen nicht mit in der Koalition
vielleicht und das kann aber auch dazu
führen herrschaya dass am Ende
Bürgerinnen und Bürger da sitzen und
sagen irgendwie kümmert sich hier jemand
wir sind unzufrieden hören uns was
Ramsauer beschrieben hat als Problem
haben wir jetzt übernommen erkannt und
deswegen gibt's ja ein
planungsbeschleunigungsprogramm und für
uns nächste Woche für uns geht jetzt ich
gebe Ihnen auch konkretes Beispiel für
uns gilt jetzt wirklich das Beispiel vom
LG germanyell als ein Musterbeispiel
dafür in Deutschland wie es gehen kann
und jetzt stellen Sie sich mal vor für
dieses Land geht zukünftig LNG
Geschwindigkeit statt Berge
Geschwindigkeit dann kommen wir doch an
die großen Fragen an die wir dringend
brauchen in der in der
planungsbeschleunigung aber auch in der
Frage der Realisierung und sie haben
vorhin das Thema Wohnungsnot
angesprochen das hier in der Stadt in
der Stadt Berlin allein hier fehlen weit
über 200.000 Wohnungen die gebaut werden
müssen und trotzdem erlaubt sich diese
statt einer Debatte über die Frage des
Eigentümers Wechsels im Sinne einer
Enteignung statt das Geld nämlich die
Milliarden die dafür notwendig werden in
geförderten oder hier in im Preis
gebundenen in miet gebundenen
Wohnungsbau zu stecken die Debatte
führen wir gar nicht stattdessen führen
wir eine ideologische Debatte und die
Leittragende sind wir Mieterinnen und
Mieter an der Stelle die in dieser Stadt
eine Wohnung suchen und das ist auch
Aufgabe der Politik sich an der Stelle
gerade zu machen und mit den
Herausforderungen richtig umzugehen
statt ideologisch Politik zu machen und
für 40 € beispielsweise um das auch noch
mal weiter in die Realität noch zu holen
das ganze Thema kriegen ihren
Einkaufswagen gar nicht mehr voll selbst
wenn man zum Discounter geht daher auch
mal die Frage hier die beiden Politiker
waren sie zum letzten Mal einkaufen und
was ist Ihnen da aufgefallen im
vorletztes Wochenende mit meiner Frau
das ist für mich immer das
hochinteressante Erfahrung wenn man am
Samstag Vormittag in der
Hauptstadt meines Wahlkreises Traunstein
mitten im Chiemgau
Urlaubsgebiet wenn man dann so schaut
was kosten die einzelnen Sachen wie sind
die teurer geworden eine Butter wie
teuer die geworden ist
drauf an wo sie hingehen ob sie zu Aldi
gehen oder oder zu Rewe und dann die ob
sie eine Eigenmarke kaufen oder Marken
oder Markenbutter aus Bergbauer Milch
von der Pidinger Molkerei oder so weiter
da liegen ja da gehen die Preise um 100
oder 150% auseinander
kaufen Sie dann die bergbauernbutter
kaufen
in berlin wenn er in Berlin
Joghurt aus Bergbauernmilch angeboten
wird von der großen
genossenschaftsmalerei in Piding z.B ja
da bin ich gern bereit für so ein
Joghurt 1,20 € oder 1 € 40 zu bezahlen
oder wunderbarer Käse von Berga oder
Käse in Waging das sind die beiden
großen Molkerei in meinem Wahlkreis da
bin ich gerne bereit für ein Kilo Käse
oder
kauft mir nicht gleich und entsprechend
weniger und das Geld hinzulegen
sich vermutlich diese Frage gar nicht
mehr stellen können ob sie bereit sind
für diese Mehrqualität das zu zahlen
weil sie sagen Eier sind beispielsweise
39% teurer geworden
dass man wo man überhaupt die beste
Qualität kriegt dann muss man die Kinder
sagt kriegen und vielleicht auch mit
einer weniger guten Qualität und ähm es
sind ja die Preise auch angestiegen dort
wo die Qualität nicht so hoch ist ich
habe neulich hier in ber im Flughafen
eine Brezel gekauft für 3,50 € da habe
ich gesagt ich fahre vom Glauben ab
welche Qualität ist in dieser Brezel
drin dass sie drei oder 50 wert sein
soll also ich hatte das Erlebnis ich
habe schon lange keinen Hund mehr oder
was heißt jetzt etwas über ein Jahr
meine Tochter hat mich gebeten Mama
bringt noch mal zwei Dosen von dem
günstigen Hundefutter mit und dann stand
ich vor der Verzweiflung im Geschäft und
hat dieses günstige Hundefutter gesucht
was ich auch ab und zu gekauft habe
festgestellt das gibt's noch das gibt
schon noch aber das kostet halt keine 75
Cent mehr die Dose sondern die kostet
jetzt 1,65 € dieselbe Dose übrigens Ring
Politiker das mit ganz oft wird
Politikern vorgeworfen nehmen die
Bodenhaftung verloren die wissen gar
nicht wie unser Leben aussieht jetzt
haben wir hier ein paar Beispiele gehört
kriegen Politiker das mit ja ich habe
selber Ausbildung Handwerk gemacht bin
gelernter Elektroinstallateur meine
Mutter ist Krankenschwester und mein
Vater Elektromeister gewesen ich kriege
das wohl mit ich war gestern früh um
5:30 Uhr auf dem Fruchthof vom
beusselmarkt hier in Berlin wo die
Händlerinnen und Händler genau
beschreiben was da passiert wenn der
Staat die Miete abgreift an der Stelle
20 % mit Steigung dann heißt es für
jedes einzelne obstteil was da am Markt
gehandelt wird für jeden einzelnen Kita
Betreiber Gastronomen für jede klinische
Einrichtung die da ihr Obst bezieht das
ist zu diesen Preissteigerung kommt weil
natürlich auch hier der Staat das ist
die die Hafen die Hafengesellschaft die
behaler die dafür verantwortlich ist in
der Stadt jetzt probierten aufholeffekt
der letzten zwei Jahre zu machen bei den
Fragen der Mieteinnahmen die entgangen
sind aufgrund der corona-pandemie das
können die Händlerinnen und Händler
nicht stemmen die sind gerade so durch
diese Pandemie gekommen und jetzt wird
ihnen quasi das Rückgrat noch mal mit
diesen Kosten gebrochen und wird
umgelegt ich sage sie müssen mir mal
richtig ran an die Steuer
Steuersenkungen vielleicht auch reiche
mehr belasten
müssen erst einmal wo der Staat in der
Verantwortung ich habe ihn ja heute
alleine in dieser Sendung schon drei
Beispiele gegeben wo der Staat als
handelnder Akteur diese
Preissteigerungen einfach eins zu eins
weitergeben oder die Inflation quasi
nicht ausgleicht obwohl er sie
ausgleichen könnte das ist Aufgabe wo
wir als erstes als Politik rankommen und
da kannst Du schon richtig was drehen
und das hatten Effekt an der Stelle auf
die Birne auf den Apfel auf die Banane
das sind genau die Punkte ich glaube
auch bei Ihnen heute in der Bild dazu
eine entsprechende Berichterstattung
gelesen zu